do you think it's a fundamentally
mathematical pursuit of trying to
understand
like the laws of this the governing our
universe from a mathematical perspective
it's almost like
if it's ai it's exploring the space of
like theorems and those those kinds of
things or is there some other
is is there some other more
computational ideas
more sort of empirical ideas they're
both i would say
it's really interesting to look out at
the landscape of everything we call
science today
so here you come now with this big new
hammer it says machine learning on it
and ask you know
where are there some nails that you can
help with here that you can hammer
ultimately if machine learning gets the
point that it can do everything
better than us it will be able to help
across the whole space of
of science but maybe we can anchor it by
starting a little bit right now near
term
and and see how we kind of move forward
so so like right now
first of all you have a lot of big data
science
where for example with telescopes we are
able to collect way more data
every hour than a grad student can just
pour over like in the old times right
and machine learning is already being
used very effectively even at mit like
to find planets around other stars
to detect exciting new signatures of new
particle physics in the sky and
to detect the ripples and the fabric of
space time
that we call gravitational waves caused
by enormous black holes crashing into
each other halfway across the
observable universe machine learning is
running and taking
right now you know doing all these
things and it's really helping
all these extra mental fields there is
a separate front of physics
computational physics which is getting
an enormous boost also
so um we had to do all our computations
by hand right
people would have these giant books with
tables of logarithms and oh my
god i just pains me to even think
how long time it would have taken to do
simple stuff
then we started to get little
calculators and computers that could
do some basic math for us now what
we're starting to see is
kind of a shift from gofy computational
physics
to neural network
computational physics what i mean by
that is
most computational physics would be done
by humans programming in the
intelligence of how to do the
computation into the computer
just as when gary kasparov got his
posterior kicked by ibm's deep blue in
chess
humans had programmed in exactly how to
play chess intelligence came from the
humans it wasn't learned right
mu zero can be not only
kasparov in chess but also stockfish
which is the best sort of go-fi
chess program by learning
and we're seeing more of that now that
shift beginning to happen in physics so
let me give you
an example so lattice qcd
is an area of physics whose goal is
basically to take the periodic table
and just compute the whole thing from
first principles
this is not the search for theory of
everything we already know the theory
that's supposed to produce as output the
periodic table
which atoms are stable how heavy they
are all that good stuff their spectral
lines
it's called it's a theory lattice qcd
you can put it on your t-shirt
or colleague frank wilcheck got the
nobel prize for working on it
but the math is just too hard for us to
solve we have not been able to start
with these equations and solve them to
the extent that we can predict
oh yeah and then there is carbon and
this is what the spectrum of the carbon
atom looks like
but uh awesome people are building these
super computer simulations
where you just put in these equations
and you
you make a big cubic lattice of space
or actually it's very small lettuce
because you're going to the subatomic
ski down to the subatomic scale
and you're trying to solve this but it's
just so computationally expensive
that we still haven't been able to
calculate things as accurately as we
measure them in many cases
and now machine learning is really
revolutionizing this so my colleague
fiola shanahan and mit for example she's
been using this really cool machine
learning technique
called normalizing flows where she's
realized she can actually speed up the
calculation
dramatically by having the ai learn how
to do things faster
another area like this where we
where we suck up an enormous amount of
super computer time to do physics
as black hole collisions so now that
we've done the sexy stuff of detecting
a bunch of this with ligo and other
experiments we want to be able to pre
know what we're seeing and so it's a
very simple
conceptual problem it's the two body
problem
newton solved it for classical gravity
hundreds of years ago but the two-body
problem is still not
fully solved for black holes black hope
for yes and
nice nice gravity because they won't
disorbit each other forever anymore
two things they give off gravitational
waves and make sure they crash into each
other
and the game what you want to do is you
want to figure out okay
what kind of wave comes out as a
function of of the masses of the two
black holes
as a function of how they're spinning
relative to each other
etc and that is so hard it can take
months of super computer time on
massive numbers of cores to do it you
know
wouldn't it be great if you can use
machine learning
to greatly speed that up right
now you can use the expensive old gophi
calculation as the truth and then see if
machine learning can figure out a
smarter faster way of getting the right
answer
yet another area like of computational
physics
these are probably the big three that
suck up the most computer
time lattice qcd black hole collisions
and cosmological simulations where you
take not a subatomic
thing and try to figure out the mass of
the proton but you
take something with it's enormous and
try to look at how all the galaxies get
formed in there oh wow
yeah there again there are a lot of very
cool ideas right now about how you can
use machine learning to
do this sort of better stuff better
the difference between this and the big
data is you kind of make the data
yourself
right so and then finally
we're looking over the physics landscape
and seeing what can we hammer with
machine learning right so we talked
about
experimental data big data discovering
cool stuff
that we humans then look more closely at
then we talked about taking the
expensive computations we're doing now
and figuring out how to do them much
faster and better
with ai
you